Hello.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update
about the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
We've partnered with Udacity
to create the VR Developer
Nanodegree.
When you take the
course, you learn
how to create 3D environments,
define behaviors, and make
VR experiences comfortable,
immersive, and performant.
To get started, follow the link
included in the description
below.
The third developer
preview of Android Wear 2.0
is now available with
Google Play on Android Wear,
making it easy for users
to find and install apps
directly on the watch.
For screenshots and details
on the other updates,
take a look at the post.
The data from Landsat
and Sentinel-2
are now available
on Google Cloud.
This puts over a petabyte
of the world's leading
public, cost-free
satellite imagery data
available at your fingertips.
The user growth that Google
Cloud customer Niantic
experienced with the launch of
Pokemon Go was extraordinary.
For some pretty absurd
graphs, and details
of what happened
behind the scenes,
take a look at this post.
Also in the category
of awesome posts,
here's one about robots learning
from each other's experiences.
And that's not the only
cool machine learning stuff
to read about.
We're introducing
Open Images, which
is a dataset consisting
of around 9 million URLs
to images that have been
annotated with labels spanning
over 6,000 categories.
We're also releasing a dataset
of 8 million YouTube video
URLs representing over
500,000 hours of video,
along with video-level
labels from a diverse set
of 4,800 knowledge
graph entities.
For more info,
and to get started
with both these datasets,
follow the links to the posts.
Native ads are less jarring
than traditional ads,
and they fit in with
app content more
naturally, providing a
better user experience.
Check out this
post for four ways
you can make UX a priority
both within your app and ad
experience.
And here's a post
and video to help
you understand how Firebase
and AdMob work together.
Follow the link to learn how to
save time by linking your AdMob
app and Firebase
project, monetize smarter
with Firebase Analytics,
and help grow your users
with Firebase.
Please remember to
subscribe and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.